okay so this was just part of a joke but
then we realized this is lucky frosted
cocoa tricks a mix of Lucky Charms
frosted flakes cocoa puffs and tricks
that amber can't have a coach she'll die
but this is gonna give us diabetes so
we'll all be shooting insulin I am
feeling people are gonna wonder how this
is I figure we just try every alright so
this is my with milk I got a little bit
of everything and I see a little bit
everything okay here we go
[Laughter]
that is like Saturday morning the cereal
it's like fruit chocolate sugar so much
sugar oh man that's just like a bunch of
sugar I could only have one more bite so
I got all that flavor oh you know
delicious if I were in another state of
mind if you were high yeah I mean we use
your when we films I could see this be I
would love this actually it is tolerable
I can even one more bite we're just
joking kids yes don't do this either
because this is also for home and drink
your milk River stain milk don't do
school and drink your drug yeah I it is
really addictive actually it's tasty
oh my god it's like awful but it gets
better and better the more you have oh
my god this yeah I got stopped I got
stopped this is like actually really
really bad no more I'll save you oh my
god yeah that's um that's just dangerous
man it's just dangerous forgot at your
humble age or not to wear of the ritual
of Saturday morning an excuse to eat
this man okay one job
hear me say poo and you're messing it up
you ruined the genius of proof and
action that's
cool and all but how about some more
violent stuff that's going on but
violence yeah guys I got stabbed
somebody finally somebody gets it I have
issues she has giggles finally somebody
gets it I have issues okay never bring
it up again
[Laughter]
okay dropping our pajamas and our kids
kids serious finally someone who
gets it do I have to worry about you
maybe finally somebody who gets it and I
got to worry about you you might help
okay but I know what you're thinking if
Beetlejuice got his own cartoon why not
Little Shop of Horrors because no one
was thinking that just for that the
plant rats
yeah
[Laughter]
now they have Oh fine I'll keep it short
guys guys
oh now on to a show I know I've barely
talked about x-men oh come on whatever
my line is you come on apparently was
the passion project of the head of Fox
Kids this is a really good book by the
way yeah one that still makes a butt ton
of money even today no no nothing at all
okay there might have been another
little hit show that was ruined by her
doing that what was that for
it was one word there's one goddamn
where with five layers you don't even
say five lies this is nice hitting the
flies around you oh yeah no there's a
lot of
[Laughter]
the gun the gun got much to our regret
much to our regret much to our regret my
god I think we're all in a goosebumps
episode guys where my god blah blah blah
it's a more hardcore it's tough I don't
know what I'd say did see again I dare
you I double dare ya now I'm mad
did you melon mad did you melon mad did
you now I'm mad you can do it get mad
you're mad
[Laughter]
okay yeah you're angry that is yes his
name is Genki like I know right right
his name is Genki so anime oh Christ I
hit an earth started with the Dreamcast
man it's fine yeah everything's gonna be
okay
things get changed ugh I don't think my
mom's gonna let me sleep over here
anymore
[Laughter]
[Music]
you